là j'ai as Valais je me pose même plus
de questions c'est boites quoi qu'il
arrive parce que techniquement il me
reste 4,8 bébé 60 ans est une vraie
passionnée de poker cet habitant de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux découvre son
appétence pour ce jeu en 2008 grâce à
son mari inscrit à l'association
vicinoise NH poker team bluff fold ou
conflip la sexagénaire aime la stratégie
et à prendre des techniques nouvelles
deux ans plus tard elle lance avec son
époux le Frenz Poker Club à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux la meilleure
école pour nous c'était d'aller jouer
dans les tournois extérieurs et
rencontrer des nouvelles personnes quand
on est dans une association on joue tout
le temps avec les mêmes personnes au
bout d'un moment on se connaît et on
avance plus dans la progression de notre
façon de jouer au poker une armoire
garnie de trophées cette ancienne
cavalière équestre pendant 30 ans à
garder son esprit de compétition en 2022
elle obtient le titre de championne de
France par équipe avec ses trois
coéquipiers sur un site internet
spécialisé malgré tout Sylvie n'a jamais
souhaité atteindre un niveau
professionnel c'est un monde à part
c'est aller jouer dans tout dans le
monde entier moi l'argent ça me fait
peur en fait j'ai pas envie d'y laisser
ma chemise ma maison perdre mon couple
perdre ma famille et rentrer dans
l'addition
[Musique]
les tournefs physiques des moments
privilégiés pour développer pleinement
son talent ses qualités une bonne
analyse des autres concurrents et
beaucoup de patience avec une stratégie
bien à elle moi je parle beaucoup sur
une table de poker donc je déstabilise
les autres joueurs qui pensent que je
les regarde pas mais en fait tout en
parlant j'observe les joueurs autour de
moi elle est devenue plus mordu que moi
elle est devenue meilleure que moi donc
voilà quoi elle a des résultats que j'ai
jamais réussi à avoir donc on peut dire
que tu es fier d'elle complètement
complètement Sylvie participera la
prochaine compétition France Poker
Series du 15 au 23 juillet à Paris les
sports de décrocher un nouveau titre
d'envergure face à plusieurs centaines
de joueurs